[MUSIC PLAYING]
VENKAT RAPAKA:
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Venkat Rapaka.
I lead the Android IoT
platform team at Google.
So being a part of
the Android team,
this is one of my favorite
times of the year.
You get to come to I/O.
You get to interact
with a lot of
developer community.
A number of our
partners also attend,
so we get to meet all of them.
But this year is
especially exciting for me
because this is
the first time we
get to talk at I/O
about Android Things,
and how we want to bring device
production capabilities to more
people.
So you probably heard
earlier today at the keynote
that Sundar kicked
off, Android now
has incredible momentum
across a number of verticals
that you see up here.
There are now two
billion devices,
two billion monthly
active devices
that run Android across
these four form factors.
And joining this family
is now Android Things.
And Android Things is
designed to extend Android
beyond these four verticals--
mobile, web, TV, and auto--
to a lot more exciting
new product categories
within the space of IoT.
And for us at Google,
this is a pretty--
it's a very interesting
area for us,
with all the innovation
that's happening now.
And we also see that there's
an opportunity and a real need
to enable developers to build
high-quality, secure devices
quickly and easily.
And finally, I think there's
an opportunity for us
to democratize IoT
device development,
and make it more
accessible to more people.
And Android Things
was created last year
as an acknowledgement of this
potential that's ahead of us.
So Android Things released in
Developer Preview in December
last year, and it's been great
to see the excitement so far,
and the momentum
that we've built up.
And in fact, we
announced at the keynote
this morning that already in
just five months up to now,
there are thousands
of developers
in more than 60 countries
who are actively
trying out Android Things.
So thank you very much for
investing your time and all
the feedback you've given us.
So IoT, of course, is very
broad and very diverse.
Within this large
space, Android Things
has targeted one of the most
exciting-- at least for us,
one of the most exciting
areas, powerful devices
that sit at the edge and that
bring on-device intelligence.
And these devices can many
use cases, both old and new.
And you can see examples
up on the screen.
At the home, think of
security systems, routers.
They've been around for as long
as most of us can remember,
but also new, interesting device
types like smart doorbells
that have cameras
built into them.
In retail, increasingly you'll
see point-of-sale machines,
vending machines
that have displays,
and that can interact with
the customer's mobile device
at the point of sale and do
some very interesting things.
When you think of
smart buildings, which
we talk about a lot,
increasingly you'll
have cameras in there.
And these cameras can not
only detect occupancy,
they can actually do a headcount
and say how many people
are in a given space
at any point of time
and interact intelligently
with other systems
within the building,
like the HVAC system,
and do something smart
with that knowledge.
And finally, of course,
truly mobile IoT applications
like asset tracking,
fleet management.
These are all
becoming much better
every day with the
ability to pull
more context from the cloud
and do something smart with it
locally.
When you look at all
of these categories,
you'll see some very interesting
common themes emerge.
One is, like I said, these
are all very powerful devices
that sit at the edge.
They perform some very complex
operations-- image processing,
audio processing-- and
they do that all locally.
There's a lot of
on-device intelligence.
And this is for a number
of different reasons
or a combination of reasons.
Sometimes it's for low latency.
You just want to
react very quickly.
And other times, it's
a fault-tolerance.
Maybe a network
is not as reliable
as you would like it to be.
And they all have a
need for deep security,
both at the device
level, but also in how
they interact with the cloud.
But unfortunately,
today I think to build
a device, any of these types
of devices, is not easy.
So let's talk with a
few of the challenges
that we see in this space
that IoT developers face.
Let's talk about the
software part of it.
So if you're a
software developer,
the amount of complexity that
confronts you is massive.
The IoT devices
that you see today
are built on a number of
flavors of operating systems,
whether it's Linux or Android.
So it's very difficult to get
the consistent and reliable
sort of APIs that
you can depend on.
It's hard to find robust
tools that you can use,
and it's also very hard to
find a community of developers
that you can reach out to
when you run into trouble.
Think of all the
basic building blocks
when you're building a product.
If you're building a product
for a consumer application,
even something as simple
as a reliable setup
flow so that the consumer
can use their mobile device
to set up the product
you're selling them,
as well as an app SDK that you
can use to build your own app,
if you think of an
enterprise use case,
having something like
zero touch provisioning,
and providing a console that
enterprise can use to manage
their fleet of devices that
may not even be coming from you
but a combination
of devices that come
from everybody, or in some
cases, providing them APIs
that they can integrate into
the console that they use,
you have to build all
of this from scratch
if you want to get started.
And finally, I think
it's really hard
to get access to third party--
sorry, went too fast.
It's really hard to get
access to third party
services like the
Google Assistant
and getting them working
out of the box, especially
if you build multiple
products in this space.
So that's the software
part of the problem.
When you get to hardware, things
get even more complicated,
right?
So not only do you have to first
pick a number of components
that you can assemble together
to build a cohesive system,
get your code running on
it, and you do all of that
just to get to the
prototype stage,
so just to do a
proof of concept.
But as you're doing
this, you need
to be really careful to make
sure you're picking components
that can scale to high volumes
when you hit mass production.
And if you don't
do that, then you
have to re-implement
a bunch of work
you did before to adapt
to the new components
that you're forced
to replace them with.
And this is not a problem that's
unique to just small or medium
companies.
Some of our largest
OEM partners tell us
how difficult this is for
them, even at the scale
that they're at,
especially when they
think of this space with
the diversity of product
categories.
And as the builder of
the product portfolio,
they also struggle
with this the same way
that a small company
would struggle.
And finally, security.
I think given the amount of
news-related, security-related
news that we see
today, I don't think
I need to belabor the point
of how important security
is in this space.
But I think, especially
in IoT scenario,
it's much harder to deliver
great security because
of the scale and the diversity
of the types of devices.
To build a really
secure device, but also
to keep it secure over a period
of time, is incredibly hard.
So with Android
Things, our goal is
to try and solve all of these
problems for the developers.
And we're doing it
in multiple ways.
One is by bringing
the power of Android
to help with
software development.
The second one is to provide
a choice of hardware solutions
that let you scale from
a prototype to production
with the confidence
that you can do
that in a quick and easy way.
And then finally,
we want to help
you keep your devices secure.
I want to talk a
little bit about what
I mean by the power of Android.
In some ways, it actually
cuts across all three
of these themes.
I mentioned the two billion
monthly active users that Dave
mentioned earlier today.
But what makes that possible
is a number of things.
All the most important
of those is the people
that are in this room--
the developer community,
the rich community that we have
of Android app developers that
make a lot of this possible.
But also we have a number
of commercial entities,
an entire supply chain,
composed of silicon providers,
people who make various
types of components, contract
manufacturers, device
manufacturers, retailers,
and seller operators,
mobile operators.
And it's a collection of
all of these, all of you,
that makes Android what it is--
a very rich, diverse,
vibrant ecosystem.
And that is what we want to
bring to the world of IoT.
So let's start first with
the developer experience
and discuss how
Android Things can
make this very consistent and
very familiar to a lot more
people.
What you see here is
the software stack
for a typical Android
mobile device, a phone.
Going from bottom to top,
the kernel in the library
is primarily focused on enabling
hardware device support,
hardware driver support.
The middle stack, the
application framework,
provides very rich services
API for the apps, which,
of course, are for a number
of developer partners,
and even Google
builds, to deliver
a variety of user-facing
services and use cases.
This stack obviously
is designed for devices
of a very specific kind.
All of them have a display.
They all expect users
to install apps.
So there's a very specific
notion that's built into these.
And we all know that IoT devices
don't exactly fit this mold.
So we set out to create a
variant of Android that's
design priority, which is
what Android Things is.
And one of the first
things they did
is they removed most of the
user-facing applications,
and a lot of the visual
framework components.
So just as an example, you
don't need a text messaging
app or a browser
on most IoT devices
or [INAUDIBLE] on any of them.
So while we did this to remove
a lot of unnecessary complexity
that developers face, one
of the happy side effects
was that we also
significantly reduced
the footprint of the
distribution, which
makes it a lot more
scalable downward
as you build IoT devices.
Then we added a number
of new capabilities
that are relevant
for IoT devices,
and touch upon a few
of them very briefly.
Let me start with Peripheral
I/O. Peripheral I/O
is a part of the Android
Things support library.
And what it does is it
provides new APIs that
allow applications that you
would build to interface
directly with low
level peripherals
using industry standard
protocols like GPIO and I2S
and so on that you
see up on the screen.
And what this enable is
that with these APIs,
your application and
your code can now
interact with the number
of peripherals like--
think of simple
things like buttons,
relays, proximity sensors, more
advanced things like displays
and speakers and
high-speed peripherals.
And over time, we're
going to add support
for things like printers,
barcode scanners, RFID readers,
and so on.
The second thing is something
we refer-- the second thing is
user drivers, which enables
a very interesting use
case for us.
So in a lot of cases,
your applications
can just use a Peripheral
I/O. But in some cases,
you might want to integrate
your hardware with the Android
framework so that you can access
some of the standard framework
managers and
callbacks and expose
these components
and the capabilities
thereof to other
applications that
might sit on your
product, applications
that you might get from a
third party, for example.
So again, as a few
quick examples,
input devices that generate
key events or motion events
can now inject those events into
the Android input framework.
Or think of GPS or
other location sources
that you attach to
your product, and this
can be integrated with the
location framework, Android
location framework.
And once you do that, location
updates from these sources
will then be delivered
through the location
manager and the fused
location providers.
So over the last five
months, we from--
at Google, we've
been adding drivers
on our open source
community GitHub
page for many different
types of peripherals.
And we've noticed that a lot
of our developer partners
are beginning to
contribute as well, which
is really awesome to see.
And increasingly,
some of our partners
are also getting
into the act now.
Just as an example,
Intel recently
added support for Android Things
with their useful packages
and modules and MRA, which
brings with it about 200 very
interesting components
and peripherals
that now work on Intel
Joule and Intel Edison
when you use Android Things.
I mentioned we removed a
lot of the visual framework
components.
And we did this because
a lot of IoT devices
don't have displays.
But at the same time,
there are definitely
quite a few that will
have a display, sometimes
more than one display.
So the way we think about
this is that display support
is optional, right?
So you can add a
display if you want.
And Android Things supports
the same UI toolkit
that's available in all the
other Android form factors.
So you can rely on
the same framework.
So if you build a device with
a display, the entire display,
the control for
the entire display
is actually handed to your
application that you build.
And what we did is
we basically got
the system UI out of the way.
So no more system status
bar, navigation buttons.
We eliminated of lot of the
APIs that don't make sense,
like showing a dialog for
authentication or sign on.
Android system notifications,
user-granted runtime
permissions, so we
removed all of these.
And we believe this
more closely mimics
the types of devices we
encounter in the IoT space,
where the devices tend
to be fixed-purpose,
and the user is interacting with
the intended purpose as opposed
to adding new functionality
through the display that's
on the device.
Moving on, let's talk about
connectivity a little bit.
Today already in the
developer previews
that we released so
far, we support Wi-Fi,
and we support Bluetooth.
We are going to bring
NFC later this year.
But the one I'm very
excited about is cellular.
So adding cellular
capabilities to IoT devices
unlocks a variety of very
exciting new use cases.
But adding cellular
support is nontrival,
as anybody in this room
who's tried can attest to.
And what you'll find is that
half the challenge is actually
enabling the functionality
and making sure it works.
The other half of it
is getting it certified
to work on carrier networks.
Especially if you have
a geographic footprint
that goes beyond one
country, that challenge
goes up dramatically.
As it turns out, the
core Android team,
which we're a part
of, works very closely
with a number of
silicon partners
in the context of mobile phones
to deliver this capability.
And as it turns
out, we're working
with some of the same
partners very closely as well.
So we're going to
leverage a lot of the work
that the core Android team does
to bring cellular connectivity
in a very clean,
easy-to-use onto Android
Things over the
course of this year.
In fact, Qualcomm
earlier this year
announced that they're going
to support Android Things
on their Snapdragon
210 processor that
also has LTE modem capability.
So I talked a lot about
the changes we made
and the things we added.
Let me now talk about the
things that we did not change,
which is the core
power and the ecosystem
that Android brings with it.
So you can still
continue to leverage
the Android SDK and
the NDK, Android Studio
to develop your use cases,
and your APKs on top,
and all the developer
tools that we provide you.
You can continue to use the
existing third party Android
libraries.
And, as importantly,
you can continue
to tap into the rich community
of Android app developers
for support and also reuse
things others build, right?
So that's one of
the exciting things
that I think Android can
bring to Android Things.
Play Services.
So Google Play Services has a
number of very interesting APIs
that people rely on.
This is currently already
available in Android Things
and Developer Preview.
What we are currently working
on is an optimized, much lighter
weight version of Play Services
that's targeted at IoT devices
that we're going to
deliver later this year.
So what we did is we
removed a number of APIs
that we talked were not useful
in this space, things that
enabled user input or user
account management, which don't
necessarily make sense in IoT.
And by doing that, we reduce the
footprint of GmsCore by a lot.
But we preserved
APIs like Firebase,
and we're adding enhanced
APIs that support
machine intelligence on-device.
And of course, I mentioned
Firebase, an incredibly
valuable tool in this space.
We are going to continue to
support that as we build out
Android Things, the ability
to access Google Cloud
Platform if you need cloud
storage and additional compute.
And we'll make that seamless
as well, that integration.
And then a lot more, right?
So even yesterday when
Developer Preview came out,
the Assistant SDK, we launched--
we provided a sample yesterday
that lets you build a Google
Assistant prototype using
Android Things, right?
And you'll see a lot more
Google services and apps
that we want to bring
to Android Things
in a cleanly integrated,
easy-to-use, modular way,
meaning you can pick
the ones you want.
So when you put all
of this together,
on the software
side, what you get
is, if you're an Android app
developer, all of a sudden,
this opens up the world
of IoT devices to you.
And you can set out on a
path to be an IoT device
developer yourself.
If you're someone
with an idea, and you
want to go build a
device, you can actually
tap into this community
of Android app developers,
and you don't have to build a
full team of deep OS experts
any longer to even get started.
You can actually pick
some of these things
that they're building and tap
into this large community,
and get going.
Finally, we did talk about
devices getting increasingly
smarter.
And I'll talk a little bit about
how we're making that happen.
So on-device
intelligence is going
to be critically important
in IoT over time.
And this can be for
a number of reasons.
One, I mentioned
before, latency.
You might want a very
quick response time.
You might have
bandwidth constraints.
Bandwidth is
expensive sometimes.
Your connectivity might be very
unreliable, and so on, right?
So with Android, the core
Android platform itself,
and also with Android
Things, we're making--
as a collective, we're
making deep investments
to bring on-device intelligence
capabilities in a very deeply
integrated fashion into
the distribution we're
going to provide you.
And earlier this year, we
added support for TensorFlow
on Android Things.
And it's been awesome to see
some of the creative things
that our community has been
already building so far.
And at our demo space, you
can see TensorFlow in action.
There are two demos,
one that our team built,
another one that somebody
in the community built
using the pieces that
we-- the components
we delivered already.
There's also a
codelab for TensorFlow
that you can go and
get your hands on it.
So I'm going to
switch gears a bit
now and move from
software to hardware
and how Android Things is going
to simplify and accelerate
your hardware prototyping
process as well.
So if you're getting
started on a new device,
as I mentioned before,
you need to assemble all
the right components,
you need to make
sure they all work together,
that your proof of concept
works.
Then you have to procure all
these components at scale,
at a price that
you're able to pay.
And you need to--
then that's when
you get to mass production.
And there's a lot of
complexity involved in this
and a lot of time as well.
So to help with
this, Android Things
uses something called a
System on Module architecture,
or the SoM architecture.
And I think a lot of
you in this audience
are probably familiar
with this concept.
A SoM basically has a
core computing module.
So it has compute,
connectivity, storage,
and many other core components
in a very small package.
And when you're
building an IoT device,
some of the most
complex hardware design
is actually already
encapsulated in the SoM itself.
And what you see here
on the left side,
my left, are two modules, one
from Intel, and one from NXP
that we already. launched.
And in close collaboration
with our silicon partners,
we're going to provide a BSP,
a Board Support Package, that
basically provides a very
clean layer for your core
to reside on top of.
And what that does is
it makes your core very
portable to other supported
hardware platforms as you build
out a portfolio of
more capable devices
within the same
category, or you're
switching to a new
category and you
want something quite different.
So let's see how a
SoM is in action.
So it's pretty hard
to see on the slide
how big these SoMs are.
So the smaller image you
see up there is this.
This is what a SoM looks like.
It's about an inch and a half
on the side, roughly a square.
And the larger image
there is the baseboard
that we use internally.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] baseboard
that we internally.
It has the kitchen sink of all
the peripherals and connections
that we need for our
own internal prototyping
and development and testing.
And of course, the
product you build
won't require all
of these components,
so you would have a baseboard
that's much simpler,
and only have the things that
you need for your product.
And baseboards typically
tend to be a lot more--
a lot less expensive to
produce, even at lower volumes.
So your prototyping
becomes a lot easier
once you start using a SoM.
And the SoM model, we
believe, offers some very key
advantages.
One is, you can get
to prototype stage
much faster by taking
off-the-shelf components.
And the pre-certified
hardware basically
reduces not only
your time to market,
but also your development costs.
It also takes out a
lot of the technology
risk inherent as you're
building your prototypes.
And of course, as you scale
to larger commercial volumes,
you can be confident
that you can
procure these in high volume.
And if you hit
really high volumes,
you can actually collapse
the baseboard and the SoM
into one board.
And you can get a custom
board built for you.
And it has couple of advantages.
One is it can reduce your cost.
Another thing is you
can then lay it out
in a way that matches the XY
dimensions of your product,
right?
So you can actually
optimize it to fit exactly
cleanly into the product
idea that you want to build.
And as long as you
use the same BSP,
you don't have to rewrite any
code that you already built.
If you want to learn
more about SoMs
and how to build
custom be BSPs--
sorry, custom boards, I think
there's a more detailed talk
coming up tomorrow at 9:30 AM.
So of course, you need SoMs
that can match the price
and power and performance
and connectivity needs
that your product has.
So to do this, we're
working with a number
of industry leaders
to make sure you have
plenty of hardware choices.
Today, we already support
boards from NXP, XP, Intel,
and Raspberry Pi, and
Qualcomm, as I mentioned,
announced earlier this year
that we are working with them
on the Snapdragon 210 line.
And we're also
working with MediaTek
to bring an option from them
as well with Android Things
support on it.
Finally, I'll talk
about security.
So thankfully, there is
now an increasing focus
on security in IoT.
And in the IoT
space, the challenge
is dramatically higher
for a number of reasons.
One is just the
diversity of the device
types, the diversity of
the operating systems
and the hardware that's
underneath, and the use cases,
but also just think about how
these devices are used today,
right?
A lot of them operate
with no user intervention
or interaction.
There is no display where you
can say something to the user.
And a lot of them are out
of sight, out of mind.
I can't remember the
last time I looked
at my Wi-Fi router,
which is sitting
in a closet under my stairs.
So not only is it hard
to build a device that's
secure when you
launch it, it's also
really hard to keep that device
secure over a period of time.
And Android Things has
been designed for security
from the ground up.
And what you see here is two
separate parts of the code.
One is the OS that's provided
by Google in close collaboration
with our silicon partners.
And what you see at the top
is the product-specific code
that's created by
the app developrs.
This is your apps, your
user drivers, and so on.
And separating these two is a
very clean Android API layer.
And what that allows
us to do is update
either of these two partitions
independent of the other
without compromising the
functionality of the product.
So it allows us to
push updates to either
of those two partitions.
So I talked about
security updates just now.
So the Android team
which we're a part of
invests a lot of energy into
delivering monthly security
updates, which we're now going
to bring to the IoT space
to Android Things.
These partitions are signed by
a trusted source for security.
Android Things
supports verified boot
so that your device is
protected against [INAUDIBLE]
that you might download.
And it's going to block
your device from booting
into an unknown
state with an image,
maybe that signature that you
don't trust or the contents you
cannot verify.
There's also A/B updates
which lets you roll back.
So if you push something
out by accident
that compromises
the functionality,
there's always a known
good image on these devices
so that you can, without having
to do something in the field,
revert back to an
known good image
and boot the device back
up and recover from there.
And to push all of these
updates and to give you
the control on
rollbacks and to also
monitor your field
of devices, we
are building
currently a developer
console that we're going
to give you access to soon.
And this same
console that's going
to be built on Google
infrastructure,
you can use that to push updates
to your partition as well.
So as you come up
with security patches
or you extend the
features and functionality
of your partition, you can
use all of our infrastructure
to push updates.
So it gives you the ability
to make your devices better
over time using
the Google backend.
So again, to quickly
summarize-- with Android Things,
we're going to bring
the power of Android
to simplify software
development.
We're going to provide you a
choice of hardware solutions
that are going to
allow you to scale
from prototype to production
easily and quickly.
And then we're going
to help you keep
your devices safe and secure.
Let me talk a bit
about where we are now.
So Developer Preview 4--
DP4-- shipped yesterday.
We added a number
of new capabilities,
like I2S support that
lets you connect up
external audio devices,
like speakers, for example.
We also added a new
SoM, the iMX 7D,
which delivers higher
performance than the 6UL
that we already
have support for.
And also, I mentioned
the Assistant SDK sample
that we delivered so you
can prototype a Google
Assistant, a Google Home-like
product for yourself using one
of our SoMs in Android Things.
In July, we're going to
hit Developer Preview 5.
We're going to rebase
to O at this time.
And we'll have a number of
new features, of course.
We're also going to launch
the Developer Console
into preview mode at that time.
And later this year, we're
going to have a number
of new features coming.
We'll have updates, Developer
Preview updates, every six
to eight weeks, roughly.
We'll have the GMSCore
for IoT variant
that I mentioned before.
We're going to have new
features like NFC support
and smart setup with
matching app SDKs.
We're going to have
a more SoMs coming
from some of the partners
that you saw just now.
And finally, towards the
very end of the year,
we're going to release Android
Things to long-term support,
and it's going to be
based on O at the time.
So you'll have LTS release
of Android Things then.
We're also going to release
a lot of the Android Things
features, like Peripheral
I/O, and user drivers to AOSP
as well.
So tomorrow, we have a number of
interesting sessions coming up
that go a lot more into
depth on some of the topics
that I just briefly
touched upon.
So these are all sessions
that are coming up.
So if you want to learn
more, please go attend them.
We also have a demo area
in the IoT Sandbox Dome
where you can see TensorFlow
in action, like I mentioned.
We have several codelabs where
you can get your hands dirty.
You can see how Android
Things can work really
well with the Google Cloud.
So there's a lot
of things that you
can do at I/O to learn
more about what we're up to
and where we're going.
There are additional
resources, of course,
beyond I/O. I'll go in order.
The very top link is a link
to our Google+ community
of developers where our
community can come to us to get
updates from us, to get
support from each other,
as well as our team.
We are pretty active
on the community
now and answer
questions when needed.
The middle link is a link to
Google's broader IoT page.
It covers our entire
spectrum of IoT offerings.
And the last one is our
developer documentation page.
And it has a number
of resources,
including code samples
that you can try out.
So this concludes our talk.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]